[Music]
[Music]
hi sweetheart why are you sitting gonna
go oh my oh one more thing I wanna don't
let the finally took today i'm marga and
15 student 9-1-1 what's your emergency
I'm calling to report a missing person
okay who is this regarding my daughter
I'm the detective assigned to your
daughter's case I need to know how
everything unfolded understood we're
gonna go lately one after steady session
Margot didn't return home Margo Kim
school has her marked as absent today -
she didn't attend school on Friday my
daughter is gonna lesson with you right
now
Margot cancelled her classes six months
ago and three she's been transferring
funds for the last six months we'll
handle the ground investigation but as a
parent you can help us with who your
daughter talks to is that something you
can do yes
do you mind answering some questions for
me to help here eat lunch alone on
Thursday every day
you don't think he's involved with
anything serious I know my daughter's
that she has friends right
I knows why did you invite her to study
boots running in the Berkeley mix dude
when was the last time you saw her she
did not run away local team has been
missing since last Thursday made in
transaction of $2,500 I know my daughter
where were you
they're teaching
our hands wear hat please you're just
getting over a cold we're sisters I
can't find them
Anna joy I checked the entire house
they're not here there's this RV and
they were playing on it there's then we
thought there were someone inside that
one one detective Loki the abductor
detectives I'm gonna find your daughters
what do you got we didn't find anything
sinks clean and that boy has never been
in trouble a day in his life
let him go what the police said they're
letting him go today why don't you sing
someone had to go arrest this guy well
he has the IQ of a ten-year-old there's
no way that he could have ducked two
girls and then make them disappear maybe
he wasn't on his own we're considering
all possibilities I don't think you are
considering all possibilities just let
me do my job keep knocking on doors
mind if I take a look around what do you
tell his name he said he took them did
he say was with anybody
we found Tucker
but someone has to make him talk what
they're gonna die five days we gotta
help we were running out of time you
don't even know better to him left he
knows where this guy is this guy's a
fake the girls are still out there
hey says I just want to let you know I
made it here mom was right
it took forever to find but it's perfect
what did you say her name is this place
was is it's paradise
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not dying here
thirty forty yards it takes in 32
seconds
if I Drive for you you give me a time
into place I give you a five-minute
window anything happens in that five
minutes and I'm yours no matter what I
don't sit in while you're running it
down I'll carry a gun I Drive so you
just moved by I know I'm in here for a
while what do you do
I Drive movies dangerous it's only
part-time you put this kid behind the
wheel there's nothing dude I want you to
meet mr. Bernie Rhodes my hands dirty
so online my husband's coming home where
is he he's in prison there's some guys
that want me to do a job for him
do it what you got there
one of those men gave you almost a job
your money is debts paid never go near
his family again I'm gonna tell you
something anybody finds out we're both
dead that's why this drivers got to go
Bernie he's gotta go
[Music]
do you miss any dreams you have our
plans for your future think you're gonna
have to put that on hold for the rest of
your life you're gonna be looking over
your show
I need an emergency assistance the Wind
River Indian Reservation I'm June banner
FBI welcome to Wyoming by yourself it's
just me that's Cory Lambert this is why
I found the body
this is a homicide I knew that girl he's
a fighter
they give six officers to cover an area
the size of Rhode Island maybe you can
help only know what the tracks say what
is it that you do again hunters so why
don't you come hunt one for me then
why would a teenage girl be out here was
she running from you looking for clues
but you're missing all the signs
shouldn't we wait for backup this isn't
land to back up Jane this is a land of
you're on your own
oh my god
you won't get the answers you're looking
for no matter what you find
why wouldn't your daughter run from home
I don't know why you didn't tell me how
do you
you cannot blink not ever this place
what it takes from us what it took from
you luck those in the Sydney
locked on them out here Nick Dunne
you're probably the most hated man in
America right now did you kill your wife
Nick everyone told us and told us
marriage is hard work not for me and
Nick I shall know my wife Amy Elliott
Dunne disappeared three days ago I had
nothing to do with the disappearance of
my wife I have nothing to hide
Sammi got friends we can talk to no not
really you don't know if she has friends
you don't know what she does all day and
you don't know your wife's blood type
this being a good guy so everybody can
see him being a good guy well you really
don't like him do you
all I'm trying to do is be nice to the
people who are volunteering to help find
Amy I will practice believing my husband
loves me but I could be wrong you see
that kind of bosses before Amy is the
kind of girl who attracts admirers
whoever took her is bound to bring her
back I'm hoping you can tell me what
this means I'm solve a meze treasure huh
I've seen this girl around here yeah I
remember her I know you I saw you with
the volunteer sign I wanted to help
what's your law she wanted a gun we are
all scared but we are all here now I
feel like something to be jettisoned if
necessary I feel like I could disappear
they lack of empathy Amy lost a lot of
blood in there then somebody mopped it
up why they mop up the blood if they're
trying to stage a crime scene whatever
they found I think it's safe to assume
that it's very bad I finally realized I
am frightened of my own husband I would
join you is if you're doing a deposition
what to say what not to say trained
monkey trained monkey who doesn't get
lethal injection she's you alive you
assaulted her it's not good enough for
you a hit or it's not even close
absolutely not I never touched her pnow
leave Nick is involved in the
disappearance of our daughter without a
body without a murder weapon their only
hope is a confession I know anything you
need to tell me
how was your marriage nice asking me if
I killed my wife man of my dreams
this man of mine thinking what about my
son look this man may kill me in her own
words this manly truth killed me you
ever hear the expression the simplest
answers often the correct one actually
I've never found that to be true I had
the craziest dream last night better
girl who's turned into a swan but her
prince falls for the wrong girl when she
kills herself
[Music]
he promised to feature me more this
season well he should you've been there
long enough and you're the most
dedicated dancer in the company or new
Swan queen
the exquisite Nina sayers I'm Lily
you're gonna be amazing I watched the
way she moves essential she's not
speaking it seduces attack it attack it
come on where'd you get these it's
nothing
you sweet girl feel my touch respond to
it so it was hard for teacher I don't
want to talk about that we really need
to relax it's the role isn't it it's all
this pressure and you would be too much
I knew it what's she doing here he made
me your alternate the only person
standing in your way is you
[Music]
Danya wireless I have my ways she's have
to be
nobody's after you
[Music]
my sweet girl money are you coming back
never yo I got our ticket out of here
rumor is this guy is sitting on at least
300 cave that's her guy
wait is he blind I messed up to rob a
blind guy isn't it
just cuz he's blind don't mean he's the
same problem
nice money's probably in there
ooh there stay right there
now we're gonna see what I see
[Music]
I'd be honest with you I am bad news I'm
not your friend
not gonna help you or break you
any questions
[Music]
I want to make something absolutely
clear if you saw it was some working
group coming the rescue
and I want you to know that you're wrong
this is it there's nobody else hidden
away on some other floor there is just
us we are failing you really believe
this story Osama bin Laden yeah
what Park convinced you her confidence
if you're right the whole world's gonna
want in on this
here's one of the disappeared ones
[Music]
[Music]